buenos días los los cancilleres de la
otan como hemos escuchado hoy van a
abordar el refuerzo de la parte este y
oriental de la alianza se trata sobre
todo de reforzar a la zona por ejemplo a
eslovaquia y ya hay refuerzos en los
países bálticos también en rumanía en
una operación liderada por francia pero
se esperar reforzar no sólo la parte del
este sino la parte del sureste entonces
enviando tropas a eslovaquia donde ahora
mismo no hay los cantiles también siguen
la sigue muy de cerca todo lo que estaba
ocurriendo en ucrania especialmente las
últimas noticias como hemos escuchado
del ataque a la central nuclear de zap
orilla al secretario general de la otan
ya lo hemos escuchado había mostrado su
enorme preocupación por la temeridad de
esta guerra ante este ataque lo ha dicho
en una declaración conjunta con el
secretario de estado norteamericano
anthony blinken que también está aquí en
bruselas quien ha recordado que la
alianza es una unión defensiva pero que
estará preparada ante cualquier
esther también se reúnen los cancilleres
de la unión europea que detalles nos
puede dar de este encuentro
si tras esta reunión de la otan los
cancilleres que formen parte de la unión
europea vienen a este edificio del
consejo de la unión europea a una
reunión a la que también está invitado
el secretario del estado blinken pero
también por videoconferencia el
canciller ucraniano dmitro o culeba en
este encuentro se habrá se hablará de
reforzar un nuevo paquete de sanciones
para explorar esta posibilidad sería un
cuarto y ha habido tres que el jefe de
la diplomacia europea se aburre y ha
recordado que serán muy duros pero que
aún así todo está encima de la mesa y
sobre estar todo encima de la mesa no se
descarta ni siquiera sanciones al gas y
al petróleo recordemos esto series el
gran ingreso que tiene rusia a esas
exportaciones por lo tanto tampoco se
descarta que pueda haber sanciones
tampoco hacia los oligarcas rusos como
he hecho recientemente estados unidos y
además también se va a hablar de los
aspectos técnicos para acabar de hacer
red de cerrar esta ayuda de armas de 500
millones de euros a ucrania